As it turns out, the internets design
is actually fundamentally insecure. Many explicit design choices
have caused the internet to be vulnerable
to different types of attacks. The internet was
designed for simplicity, and as a result
security was not a primary consideration when the
internet was originally designed. Another aspect of the
internet's design is that it's on by default.
In other words, when a host is connected
to the internet, it is by default reachable by
any other host that has a public IP address.
This means that if one has an insecure host,
that host is effectively wide open to attack by
other hosts on the internet. Now, this wasn't a
primary design consideration when the internet consisted of a
small number of trusted networks, but as the internet
has continued to grow, this on by default design,
or the notion that any host should always be
reachable by any other host has come under fire.
Part of the reason that their on by default model
does not work that well is that hosts are
insecure. This makes it possible for a remote attacker to
compromise a machine that's connected to the internet. And
commandeer it for the purposes of attack. In many cases,
an attack might actually just look like normal
traffic. For example, in the case of an attack
on a victim web server, every individual request
to that web server might look normal, but the
collection of requests together, mounted as part of
a, distributed denial of service attack. Might add up
to a volume of traffic that the server
is unable to handle. Finally, the internet's federated design,
obstructs cooperation for diagnosis or mitigation. In other words because the
internet is run by tens of thousands of independently run networks, it can be
very difficult to coordinate a defense against an attack because each of
these networks is run by different
network operators, sometimes in completely different countries